und als treue Phoenix Zuschauer erinnern
und Zuschauer wissen sie es natürlich
wir berichten in dieser Woche wieder
ausführlich aus dem Bundestag
haushaltswoche und die hat für sie er
hat schärfer im Blick
ja vielen Dank und es ist ja nicht nur
haushaltswoche heute die jedenfalls der
schlussttag und die Schlussabstimmung
dann gegen Mittag ca 12 30 13 Uhr
irgendwo in diesem Zeitraum sondern es
wird noch ein ganz wichtiges Gesetz
beschlossen gleich am Anfang jedenfalls
hier im Bundestag nämlich das
bürgergeldgesetz das ja zurückgekommen
ist aus dem Vermittlungsausschuss und
dann hier noch mal abgestimmt wird und
dann geht es ganz zügig rüber in den
Bundesrat und wird auch da noch mal
abgestimmt gilt mittlerweile als
Formsache aber hat ja doch einiges an
Schlagzeilen ausgelöst gucken wir
schnell auf den letzten Tag dieser
haushaltswoche und der beginnt in der
Tat dann wenn das Bürgergeld wenn die
Abstimmung zum bürgergeldgesetz gelaufen
ist mit dem Einzelplan 09 das ist der
Etat des Bundesministers für Wirtschaft
und Klimaschutz von den Zahlen her gar
nicht mal so der größte glaube der acht
größte Etat insgesamt gerade mal 3% des
gesamt machte dieser Haushalt aus und
Geld sind das 14,5 Milliarden aber er
ist ganz wichtig weil es um neue
Technologien geht um die Förderung
beispielsweise von Immobilität von Luft
und raumfahr aber auch von Energie
Nachhaltigkeit und Nachhaltigkeit und
Klimaschutz all da versuchte das
Bundesministerium ja anzuschieben
zumindest und einige was einiges auf den
Weg zu bringen man könnte also sagen
dieses Ministerium hat die Zukunft im
Blick man könnte aber auch sagen es hat
vor allem die Gegenwart im Moment zu
bearbeiten nämlich was die
Energieversorgung und die Energiepreise
angeht also viel Stoffe hier zu diesem
Thema und zu diesem Etat und wir wollen
vorher schon ein bisschen drüber reden
ich freue mich dass da sind wenn
Christian Kindler der
haushaltspolitische Sprecher der Grünen
Fraktion aber natürlich mit Hintergrund
Umwelt und Klimaschutz und Ralf lenkert
ist bei uns der diesen Einzelplan und
nur ganz ordentlich kennt aber auch
Sprecher ist für Energie und Klimaschutz
in der Fraktion DIE LINKE einen schönen
guten Morgen ihnen beiden Herr Kindler
wie kann dieser eckhar und wie will
dieses Ministerium die
Preise die im Moment ja wirklich
explodieren quasi wieder unter Kontrolle
bringen und wieder bezahlbar machen
indem er die Strom- und gaspreisbremse
jetzt einführen wir haben ja mit dem
wirtschaftabilisierungsfonds 200
Milliarden Euro bereitgestellt dass ein
großer Abwehrschirm für unsere
Volkswirtschaft für die vielen Menschen
Unternehmen vielen sozialen
Einrichtungen Vereine in diesem Land und
wir werden die Strom und Gaspreise für
ein bestimmtes Niveau auch Deckeln damit
eben Menschen eben und Unternehmen in
diesem winterplanungssicherheit haben
das ist die aktuelle Reaktion darauf an
der ja schon eine ganze Weile auch
gearbeitet wird und viele drauf warten
dass tatsächlich auch bald mal was
passiert wie was man kann das
Ministerium Perspektive leisten
perspektivisch werden wir einfach dafür
sorgen dass wir Klima neutral werden und
dass wir mit erneuerbaren Energien wie
Wind und Sonne die uns keine Rechnung
schicken ihm dann deutlich auch die
Energiekosten runter senken wir haben ja
momentan eine Fossil getriebene
Inflation war einige vor allen Dingen an
den Inflation die dich die hohen
Gaspreise kommt und ich Spekulation noch
zusätzlich anhalten das ist ein fossiles
Problem und das müssen wir überwinden
auch wegen der Klimakrise und deswegen
haben wir auch ganz zentral nicht nur um
Einzelplan 09 sondern auch um großen
klimotransformationsfonds wurden
Großteil der Gelder auch vom
Wirtschafts- und klimaminister Habeck
bewirtschaftet werden große
Investitionen vor im Bereich des grünen
Wasserstoffs im Bereich der
Gebäudesanierung im Bereich des
klimaneutralen Umbaus der Industrie wir
haben rekordinvestitionen in diesem
Haushalt insbesondere für Klimaschutz
und Transformation und so wollen wir uns
unabhängig machen auch von fossilen
Energien aber auch von Autokraten nicht
nur aus Russland auch überall auf der
Welt vor allem auf den letzten Punkt
haben wir gleich noch mal weil da ist ja
ein Zwischenschritten nötig irgendwie
überleben fossile Energieträger das ist
ja ganz spannend wenn wir gleich noch
mal ein bisschen über lG und die Kosten
für die Terminals Herr Lenkrad wie sehr
sind sie überzeugt von den Konzept dass
der Kinder hier gerade erläutern hat es
ist nicht ausreichend also es ist
natürlich richtig die erneuerbaren
Energien
Strompreis Bremsen aus unserer Sicht
viel zu hoch aber wenn wir nicht das
gesamte
Strommarkt ist ein komplett ändern wird
man sich in den Griff kriegen also ein
einfaches Beispiel nächstes Jahr werden
13 Milliarden Euro allein dafür benötigt
um den Strom handelt sicherzustellen
zwischen Nord- und Süddeutschland die
Europäische Union hat vorgeschlagen
Deutschland in zwei stromhandelszonen zu
trennen dann könnten wir uns diese 13
Milliarden sparen die werden die
vermissten die VerbraucherInnen
Verbraucher zahlen sie werden jetzt aus
dem Resten des erneuerbaren Energien
Fonds genommen für nächstes Jahr über
nächstes Jahr funktioniert nicht oder
System bei Strompreisen es ist doch
Irrsinn wenn ein Unternehmen eine
erzeugungstechnologie die zehn Cent
braucht für die Kilowattstunde
Produktion mit gewinnen dann vielleicht
18 im Moment sogar 25 30 Cent bekommt
wobei das stromagte sein so ist das muss
kann man ändern das muss man ändern das
wäre dringend nötig das zu unternehmen
weil wenn das nicht geändert wird
so viel Strompreis bremsen kann kein
Bundeshaushalt finanzieren die dann
notwendig werden um bezahlbare
Energiekosten sicherzustellen Merida
müssen wir glaube ich mit einem Satz
noch mal sagen auch wenn es viele
inzwischen natürlich wissen ist
irgendwie der das Prinzip das im Grunde
das teuerste der am teuersten
hergestellte Strom den Preis für alle
anderen auch bestimmt was ist denn ihr
Konzept ja das ist mehr oder System muss
sofort weg beziehungsweise massiv
überarbeitet eine Höchstgrenze gibt für
jede kraftwerksorte zum Einspeisen das
zweite ist wir brauchen einheitliche
Netzentgelt in der Bundesrepublik die
Ausgleich über alle Ebenen weil wir
haben Unterschiede zwischen 15 sind
zwischen den höchsten und den
niedrigsten Netzentgelt für
endverbrauchen Verbraucher das ist nicht
fair und gerade dort wo erneuerbare
Energien besonders stark ausgebaut sind
ist der Strompreis am höchsten
marktwirtschaftlich irre in Bayern wo es
kaum Strom gibt ist der Strompreis am
niedrigsten in Schleswig-Holstein
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern ist ja am
höchsten der Endpreis für Strom das muss
geändert werden das wollen wir ändern
und natürlich wollen wir auch noch
insgesamt ich sage es ganz deutlich die
Erpressbarkeit des Staates der
Gesellschaft durch das Privateigentum an
Energieinfrastruktur wie wir es eben bei
Gazprom gesehen haben muss überwunden
werden wir müssen das vergesellschaften
jetzt haben wir ziemlich viele Punkte
Herr gittler
ja das Problem war jetzt fangen wir mit
den Netzentgelten mal an wie können wir
den Netzentgelten gerne anfangen wir
können auch mit dem stromerhaltig sein
anfangen das Problem ist müssen jetzt
sehr sehr kurzfristig und sofort zu
schaffen und der Energie-System
stabilisieren das übrigens auch kein
deutsches Energiesystem ist sondern wir
haben eine europäischen Strommarkt wir
haben eine europäisches
Gasmarkt das heißt wir müssen auch
gucken was wir kurzfristig hinbekommen
und alle Experten und Experten sagen wir
müssen dann Strom auf die sein ran ja
aber das geht nicht innerhalb von zwei
Monaten dafür brauchen wir
wahrscheinlich mehrere Jahre weil es so
komplex ist weil es EU für recht
betrifft weil es viele andere Länder
auch in Europa mit beeinträchtigen und
beeinbeziehen muss deswegen wollen wir
daran aber man kann das so kurzfristig
nicht machen so muss jetzt kurzfristig
gucken wie man die Preise runterbringt
dafür haben wir die Strom und
gaspreisbremse eingeführt zu Gast kommt
gar nicht nur sagen die Linke hat ja
auch lange einfach auch Nordstemmen eins
und trotzdem zwei festgehalten und Teile
der Linken vor dann immer noch dass wir
die Pipeline aus Russland wieder
benutzen so wie Klaus Ernst also von
daher kann ich die Kritik nicht ganz
nachvollziehen noch mal kleinen Exkurs
zu Nord Stream 1 aber wirklich einen
kleinen kleinen
Diskurs wir haben eindeutige
Parteibeschlüsse wir sind aber eine
pluralistische Partei das heißt bei uns
darf jeder auch seine eigene Meinung
äußern die Fraktion ist eindeutig die
Partei steht eindeutig notstring 2 ist
technisch überflüssig gewesen jetzt ist
es technisch nicht mehr einsetzbar es
gelb hätte genügend Kleidung gegeben und
im übrigen mit einer besseren
Diversifizierung der Belieferung wenn
man zum Beispiel auch den Deckel für die
Einspeisung von Biomethan endlich
aufheben würde könnten wir die
Eigenversorgung auch erhöhen das heißt
es gäbe genügend Möglichkeiten die
Gasversorgung sicherzustellen auch ohne
diese Leitung deswegen haben wir auch
diese Beschlüsse und das einige
natürlich immer laut schreien das ist
bei jeder Partei so wie die anderen
besonders laut aber okay
ein anderes Stichwort das Herr Längert
eben genannt hat war er pressbarkeit
durch
beispielsweise auch Länder
die sagen wir mal zumindest zweifelhafte
im Regierungssysteme haben das bahnt
sich ja jetzt auch wieder rund um das
Thema LNG dann noch mal an wie stehen
Sie dazu also wir haben seit 2014 davon
gewarnt 192 in Betrieb zu nehmen wir
hatten leider recht weil wir uns
erpressbar gemacht haben vom russischen
Diktator wir haben aber auch schon lange
gewarnt dass wir uns von Öl von Gas und
von Kohle abhängig machen wo vielfach
die Ressourcen in diktatorischen oder
autokratischen Regime liegen deswegen
haben die Grünen lange für die
Energiewende gekämpft sie wurde lange
blockiert insbesondere von der CDU
deswegen machen wir es mit
höchstschritten daran dass zu beenden
wir haben das größte Paket von
erneuerbaren Energien seit 20 Jahren vor
der Sommerpause durch den Bundestag
gebracht dass er das ohne die grüne
dieser Regierung nicht gegeben und wir
werden vor allem auch einen starken
Schwerpunkt Energieeffizienz setzen sehr
ambitionierten Gesetz für
Energieeffizienz und wir werden bei den
Strom und gaspreisbremse auch darauf
achten dass vor allen Dingen auch viel
Gas und Strom auch einsparen weil wir
müssen eine gefährliche Gase mangelage
in diesem Winter verhindern das können
wir bei höchstwahrscheinlich aber wir
müssen immer runterkommen mit der
Energie vor allem nicht Effizienz zu LNG
machen wir gleich
meine Vorlage deswegen muss ich mich
entschuldigen ein bisschen nach hinten
verschieben ich habe das irgendwie etwas
leichtfertigt gerade nach vorne
geschoben aber was sie gerade vom Thema
Einsparungen reden was ist der Stand der
Dinge können Sie das sagen
ich war ja immer von 20% die Rede sowohl
Haushalt ist einsparen sollten private
als auch Unternehmen ich weiß gar nicht
habe ich jetzt schon eine ganze Weile
nichts mehr gehört ob Sie ob das
tatsächlich funktioniert ich habe nicht
was Müller die Woche geredet so wir sind
ungefähr bei Unternehmen jetzt bei
Einsparung war ca 25% Gas bei privaten
Haushalt sehen wir sogar jetzt zum stand
jetzt ca 40 % Einsparung bei Gas also
sehr große Erfolge die wir jetzt haben
wir müssen ihm gucken wie weit das eben
auch diesen Winter nach durchträgt und
wie das langfristige Effekte auch ist
sind weil ja auch Glas wir können nicht
auf Dauer fossile Preise funktionieren
also war das zusammen so funktionieren
wir auch fossile Preise wir brauchen
dafür auch execzenarien weil wir nicht
mehr billiges russisches Gas auf Dauer
haben werden und das ist auch sinnvoll
ist wegen der Klimakrise müssen wir
gucken dass wir mehr Energie einsparen
effizienter nutzen Herr Lenker direkt
dazu wenn Sie mögen direkt dazu
sicherlich müssen wir aus dem pausieren
raus aber parallel und eben auch um das
finanzieren zu können und eben auch
bessere entlastungspakete finanzieren zu
können ist das zwingend erforderlich
dass man die extra Gewinne der Konzerne
ordentlich besteuert eine
übergewinnsteuer ist unerlässlich und
die darf sich nicht mehr auf den
Energiesektor beschränken ein einfaches
Beispiel Kali und Salz hat sein Umsatz
im Geschäft ja mit 20% weniger
kalkuliert aber ein fünfachen gewinnen
das heißt also Preissteigerung auf
ganzer Front die durchgesetzt werden
können weil Mangel da ist und diese
übergewinne die nicht mit Investition zu
tun haben nichts mit ich sag mal reale
Arbeit die müssen kassiert werden und
dann haben wir auch genügend um eine
bessere gaspreisbremse um einen besseren
Preis Bremse zu bezahlen das ist ja
geplant und das ist Vorhaben der
Koalition
dass man sich da so zumindest sagen dass
einige Kommentatoren doch
vergleichsweise genügsam zeigt wenn man
versucht irgendwie mal gerade eine
Milliarde Euro dazu erheben auf diesem
Weg na wir werden ja übergewinne gerade
im Energiesektor abschöpfen das haben
wir jetzt auch noch mal beschlossen im
Bereich von Kohle Atomen auch
erneuerbaren Energien wo einfach hohe
Gewinne angefallen sind und einfach
nicht gerechtfertigt sind durch
Investitionen das werden wir machen die
strompreisbremse zu finanzieren wir
haben jetzt auch noch mal deutlich
gemacht dass wir auch im Bereich der
Ölunternehmen und mineralwirtschaft das
abschöpfen wollen das hätten als wir das
zuerst gefordert haben als Grüne haben
viele gesagt das werdet ihr die
durchsetzen jetzt haben wir davon
wichtigen Schritt erzielt wir
diskutieren in der Koalition noch über
genau Ausgestaltung aber das sind
wichtiger Schritt für mehr Gerechtigkeit
in dieser Krise jetzt kommen wir zum
Thema LG damit wir das noch hinkriegen
weil wir so dramatisch viel Zeit jetzt
auch nicht mehr haben und weil ich
vorhin auch schon mal angesprochen habe
sie können ihre kurze Bemerkung noch
machen die ihnen auf der Zunge die
meisten übergewinde sind angefallen
zwischen November übrigens schon vor dem
Krieg Russlands gegen die Ukraine bis
August und sie soll erst ab September
eingeführt werden also insofern
verzichtet die Regierung leider auf
einen Großteil möglicher Einnahmen
außerdem ist das bemessen die
messungsgrundlage viel zu klein aber
dass er im Prinzip aber
diese ganzen Fragen diskutieren in der
Koalition auch noch mal drüber bei der
nächsten Gelegenheit die Kosten für
Terminals für LNG kommen wir in dieser
Woche in dieser Woche hören haben sich
verdoppelt von ursprünglich mal um die
drei Milliarden Euro jetzt auf
sechseinhalb was ist denn das schief
gelaufen einerseits werden jetzt mehr
Terminals ähm für für mobile LNG Schiffe
es geht hier am fslus also mobile LED
Schiffe werden mehr Terminals
bereitgestellt von der Bundesregierung
oder aber vorher schon ausgegangen von
designal nein wir sind jetzt bei sechs
Schiffen das noch mal eine Erhöhung die
Laufzeiten werden zum Teil länger und
trotzdem ist es so dass die
Weltmarktpreise explodieren und wir aber
im Haus des Autos gesagt haben wir
brauchen dafür einen Gesamtkonzept wir
haben wir in vielen Bereich erreichen
auch hier
Gelder zum Teil gesperrt und wir haben
eingefordert dass eben die
Bundesregierung jetzt ein Gesamtkonzept
für die LNG Förderung von festen
Terminals von mobilen Terminals
anschaffen muss weil wir mehr
Transparenz über Kosten und über die
Kapazitäten und auch die vereinbarkeiten
den Klimaschutzgesetz brauchen ich habe
gelesen die Betriebskosten seinen Schuld
und nötige Infrastrukturmaßnahmen an die
man am Anfang nicht gedacht hat und was
auch immer das im Detail heißt und
dadurch sind die kostenfrei haben sich
verdoppelt es gibt verschiedene Effekte
so im Kern ist es natürlich so dass wir
bis Anfang Februar überhaupt gar nicht
über LNG nachgedacht haben in
Deutschland jetzt kurzfristig um satteln
müssen und gleichzeitig eben auch die
Firmen sehr günstigen Lage für sie sind
weil eben ganz viele Länder der Welt
jetzt zusätzlich Energie beschaffen auch
das nachher fossiles Gas auch da müssen
wir rauskommen auch das kann kurzfristig
und die Gasversorgung sicher wir müssen
aufpassen das wäre doch da mittelfristig
keine Fossil neuen Abhängigkeit schaffen
deswegen haben wir das auch gesagt wir
brauchen mehr Transparenz über die
Kosten über die Kap Aktivitäten und über
die Risiken dieser Projekte und haben
dann klaren Bericht der Bundesregierung
angefordert diese neuen Abhängigkeiten
ist genau das was sie befürchten oder
wie befürchten wir uns vor allen Dingen
befürchten wir dass eben eine fossile
Infrastruktur auf Jahrzehnte festgelegt
wird das Lieferverträge eben über 20
Jahre abgeschlossen werden und wenn man
natürlich ein lng-terminal festbaut ist
ich meine das nicht die flexible dann
muss natürlich über Jahre betrieben
werden damit das nicht rechnet und diese
Behauptung man könnte die Infrastruktur
weiterverwenden die stimmt einfach nicht
okay die Hafenanlage kann man weiter
verwenden die Anlegestelle den Landstrom
kann weiter verwenden eventuell kann man
noch die Leitung umrüsten auf
Wasserstoff aber alles was Pumpen es
entspannungsanlagen die ganzen
technische Equipment ist nicht nutzbar
für andere Sachen es wäre klüger die
festen Bauten sofort in Wasserstoff oder
Ammoniak zu investieren bei ansonsten
sind die festen energy Terminals eine
tote Investition die uns eigentlich
leisten können
das ist ja doch ein relativ harsches
Urteil erstens wird das mit geplant also
müssen genau gucken bei Ammoniak und bei
grünen Wasserstoff dass das mitgeplant
wird gerade bei den Festen Terminals die
Frage ist aber wie viel brauchen wir
eigentlich auch davon weil wir natürlich
auch jetzt sehr viele mobile Schiffe
auch haben und noch mal kurzfristig sind
wir unabhängig vom russischen Gas
deswegen mussten wir auch andere Quellen
kurzfristig für die Gasversorgung uns
holen aber am Ende darf es nicht dazu
führen damit ich mir den Lenkrad einig
dass sie im fossile Abhängigkeiten
kommen dass wir am Ende zu viel Geld
bezahlen und dass wir den wichtigen
Umbau auf grünen Wasserstoff auf einmal
nackt oder von erneuerbare Energien auf
Einsparung Effizienz von Energie dass
wir das durch zu hohe Kosten und zu viel
Kapazität kaputt machen da werden wir
sehr genau achten im Parlament in dem
Haus aus Autos ganz kurz zum Abschluss
weil wir hier über Energiepreise geredet
haben und auch die Versuche die zu
deckeln und für die Verbraucherinnen und
Verbraucher einigermaßen er trägt sich
zu halten was ist ihre Prognose der
Lenkrad für die Entwicklung der
Energiepreise in den nächsten drei vier
fünf Monaten hängt davon ab ob man die
Spekulation bekämpft wenn man sie nicht
bekämpft werden sie auf dem hohen Niveau
bleiben auf dem sie jetzt sind dann
reichen die Hilfspakete definitiv nicht
okay dann braucht man eine Unterstützung
auch um die höheren Preise im gesamten
Lebensmitteleinzelhandel überall
abfangen zu können durch die Inflation
im auch durch Energiepreise verursacht
und da wäre es unerlässlich dass man für
die kleinen mittleren Einkommen eine
monatliche Pauschalzahlung hinzunimmt
aus unserer Sicht von 75 € je Haushalte
im Monat und 50 € je Person im Haushalt
Umfeld
wie die Menschen entlassen Kindergeld
mit einem höheren Wohngeld höheren ag2
Bezügen wir haben Rentnerin Studierende
Azubis unterstützt das 49 Euro
eingeführt also die Bundesregierung
macht sehr viel und diese Koalition für
Unterstützung von kleinen mittleren
Einkommen wir müssen leider Schluss
machen weil es geht nämlich gleich
drinnen los und ich glaube nicht dass
sie zu spät kommen wollen sagen Sie mir
noch in einem Satz ihre Prognose für die
Energiepreise in kurzen wenn es geht
kurzen sehen wir dass die Preise sinken
und ich gehe davon aus dass wir
hinbekommen werden dass sie auch weiter
sinken werden Herr
lenkert Herr Kindler vielen Dank dass
Sie heute morgen hier gewesen sind
vielen Dank für das lebendige und aber
trotzdem konstruktive Gespräch